[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Endlich ist es wieder soweit.
Es kommt ein neuer Kinofilm
und ich freue mich schon richtig drauf,
denn ich wurde gefragt,
ob ich zum neuen Kinofilm von Tom und Jerry eine Torte backen möchte.
Möchte ich natürlich und ich würde sagen,
wir schauen uns den Trailer an,
Damit ich auch weiß und damit ihr wisst,
worum es sich handelt.
Und später gibt's dann auch noch ein Gewinnspiel,
bei dem ihr richtig tolle Preise gewinnen könnt.
Also Film ab.
[♪ Bruno Mars - Count on me ♪]
ERZÄHLER: Nachdem sie ihr Leben lang die wohl weltberühmtesten Feinde waren,
♪ You can count on me like 1, 2, 3, I'll be there ♪
wollen Tom und Jerry nochmal ganz von vorne anfangen…
♪ 'Cause that's what friends are supposed to do ♪
[Vorbeirauschender LKW]
… in der großen Stadt.
[Musik]
Dieses Hotel beherbergte 4 Präsidenten, 3 Päpste, 2 Könige
und jetzt richten wir die Hochzeit des Jahrhunderts aus.
[Elefanten trompeten]
Denken Sie, Sie sind für diese Position qualifiziert?
Ich scheine erst richtig unter Druck
- wie ein Diamant, Rihanna-mäßig. [Lacht]
Und noch etwas:
Wir haben ein neues Problem.
Ein was für ein Ding?
Ich fange sie, Sir.
[Musik]
Oh wow, wie ausführlich!
Wir könnten einen Kammerjäger engagieren
oder wir nutzen einfach viele Millionen Jahre Raubtierevolution.
[Musik]
[Jerry lacht]
Wenn auch nur ein Foto von dieser Maus getweetet wird
auf InstaBookFace oder Ticky Tok,
sind wir ruiniert.
[Tom schreit]
Nein Sir, das wird nicht passieren.
Dieser Nager ist erledigt.
[Musik]
Ich lasse nicht zu,
dass dieses Hotel wegen einer Katze und einer Maus vor die Hunde geht.
Er spielt mit uns.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ich habe das Problem gelöst.
Wirklich?
[Musik und Elefanten trompeten]
[Musik]
[Miau]
[Seufzt]
Der Trailer sieht schon mal richtig vielversprechend aus.
Wir werden uns den Film auf jeden Fall anschauen.
Er ist bestimmt richtig amüsant.
Wie ich sehen kann,
gibt's eine Bollywood-Hochzeit im Hotel in New York.
und Tom und Jerry mischen die Party so richtig auf.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
mach ich einfach eine Hochzeitstorte.
Es ist sowieso gerade Hochzeitssaison
und Hochzeitstorten sind immer schön.
Deswegen plane ich jetzt eine dreistöckige Hochzeitstorte für euch.
[Musik]
Ja, auf jeden Fall dreistöckige,
schöne Schichten mit rein,
Frucht auf jeden Fall mit rein,
locker leichte Böden,
schön weiß und dann ausdekorieren mit vielen schönen Blumen.
Normalerweise habe ich die letzten Jahre immer
viele Blumen aus Blütenpaste selber modelliert,
Aber der Trend geht schon immer zu echten Blumen.
Deswegen kommen da, glaube ich, ganz viele echte Blumen drauf.
[Nachrichtenton]
Warte mal kurz.
Ich habe eine Nachricht von den Hauptdarstellern gekriegt,
von Terence, Kayla und Chef Jackie.
Wartet mal, schauen wir uns mal an…
Hi Deutschland! Hi Sally!
Dieses Hotel richtet die Hochzeit des Jahrhunderts aus.
[Beschreibt eure perfekte Hochzeitstorte]
Die perfekte Torte war meine eigene.
Irgendetwas mit Schokoladenüberzug in 15 Schichten…
Verschiedene Sorten in jeder Schicht…
Eine leckere Vanille-Eiscremetorte…
Kein Obst, nur Schokolade auf Schokolade und Schokolade.
Das Eis war geschmolzen und sie ist zusammengestürzt.
Ich lasse nicht zu,
dass dieses Hotel wegen einer Katze und einer Maus vor die Hunde geht.
Okay Sally, zeig uns, welchen Kuchen du jetzt backst…
und vergesst nicht, euch Tom und Jerry im Kino anzusehen!
Oh! [Lacht]
Okay.
Ähm, ja…
Ich würde sagen, ich habe ja drei Stockwerke.
Da ist auf jeden Fall für jeden was dabei.
Ich mache ein Stockwerk komplett ohne Früchte,
ein Stockwerk mit Tons of Flavours,
ganz viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen.
Ich schau einfach, dass für jeden was dabei ist.
Aber ich glaube, es geht in die richtige Richtung.
Eine schöne Hochzeitstorte, viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen,
toll hochgestapelt, schön dekoriert.
Und dann schauen wir mal, was Tom und Jerry damit anrichten.
Los geht's mit dem Backen.
Meine dreistöckige Hochzeitstorte wird jetzt folgendermaßen aufgebaut.
Das oberste Stockwerk ist mit 15 cm im Durchmesser das kleinste.
Das mittlere hat 20 cm und das unterste 25 cm.
Ich werde das jetzt so machen,
dass praktisch jedes Stockwerk was anderes anspricht
und einfach anders schmeckt.
Das oberste soll sozusagen das Kinderstockwerk sein.
Es soll ein bisschen nach bunten Süßigkeiten schmecken.
Das werde ich mit Hitschler Süßigkeiten vollpacken
und einfach etwas Schönes, Buntes mit Konfetti reinbauen.
Das mittlere Stockwerk ist für alle, die Früchte gerne mögen.
Deswegen kommen da verschiedene Fruchtmischungen mit rein
und eben auch eine leckere Creme, die das ganze abrundet.
Das letzte Stockwerk, das unterste,
ist praktisch die Schokoladentorte schlechthin.
Da kommt eine Schokoladentorte mit verschiedenen Schichten zustande.
Am Ende soll die ganze Torte aber außen natürlich weiß sein
und es kommt praktisch eine Grundcreme
als weiße Schicht noch obendrauf.
Jetzt starte ich mit der untersten Torte,
denn natürlich geht es beim Hochzeitstortenbacken auch darum,
Zeit zu sparen.
Und deswegen beginnt man beim Größten und geht dann zum Kleinsten.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon einmal die Zutaten
für einen Haselnuss-Schokoladenboden.
Dafür nehme ich 6 Eier, 300 g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz und Tonka Wonka.
Hier hab ich jeweils 300 g Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch,
400 g Mehl, 50 g Kakao, 200 g Haselnüsse (geröstet),
100 g Schokoladenstreusel und 1 Päckchen Backpulver (= 3 TL).
Wichtig ist hier, dass die Eier zimmerwarmen sind,
dass die Buttermilch auch nicht mehr so kalt ist.
Und ihr könnt auch hier, wenn es Erwachsenentorte sein soll,
die Buttermilch auch teilweise ersetzen durch z.B.
Haselnusslikör, Kaffee oder durch andere Geschmäcker,
die ihr gerne mögt.
Jetzt werde ich zuerst einmal die Eier mit dem Zucker, Salz
und Tonka Wonka etwa 10 bis 15 Min. lang cremig rühren,
bis die Masse richtig schön weißcremig ist.
In der Zwischenzeit kann ich die Haselnüsse schon einmal fein mahlen
und dann gebe ich die Flüssigkeit mit dazu
und rühre sie ganz vorsichtig und nur kurz in den Teig ein.
Die übrigen Zutaten, also Mehl, Kakao und Backpulver,
vermische ich und siebe sie in den Teig
und gebe dann noch
die gemahlenen Haselnüsse und Schokoladenstreusel dazu.
Der Teig wird jetzt nur noch ganz kurz verrührt,
damit das Volumen nicht verloren geht.
Ich backe jetzt den Teig in zwei Tortenringen.
So verkürzt sich die Backzeit auf jeden Fall
und der Teig geht noch einmal gleichmäßiger auf,
denn es ist schon eine relativ große Menge.
Ich habe die Öfen auch schon auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt
und habe die Ringe etwas kleiner als 25 cm eingestellt,
also ungefähr 24,5 cm,
weil ich später die etwas kleinere Größe zum Glattstreichen brauche.
Falls ihr nur einen Ofen besitzt,
dann könnt ihr entweder bei Heißluft backen
oder ihr backt einfach erst einmal die Hälfte
und dann die andere Hälfte.
Aber auf jeden Fall nie den Teig stehen lassen,
sondern wirklich direkt verarbeiten.
Also falls ihr wirklich nur die Hälfte zubereiten könnt,
dann erst einmal eine Hälfte Teig zubereiten, backen
und dann die übrige Hälfte.
[Musik]
Während die Kuchenböden noch im Ofen sind,
kann ich mich schon einmal um die mittlere Torte kümmern.
Die besteht aus einem Biskuit,
den ich mit einer Limette verfeinere,
weil sie ganz gut zur fruchtigen Torte passt.
Den Biskuit bereite ich zu aus
8 Eiern, 200 g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt,
200 g Mehl und 1 Limette, deren Schale unbehandelt ist.
Hierfür schlage ich jetzt zuerst einmal die Eier
mit dem Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt
etwa 10 bis 15 Min. richtig cremig auf.
[Musik]
Die Limettenschale kommt dann auch noch direkt dazu
und wird fein gerieben
und das Mehl kann dann gesiebt und vorsichtig untergehoben werden.
Den Biskuit füllt ihr dann in eure Backringe.
Die hab ich jetzt wieder ein bisschen kleiner als 20 cm eingestellt,
19,5 cm.
Ihr könnt jetzt entweder in 2 oder in 3 Backringen backen.
Ich mache es jetzt wieder in 3, um die Backzeit zu verkürzen.
[Musik]
Und die dritten Boeden werden gebacken aus.
4 Eiern, 200 g Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 200 g Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch, 300 g Mehl,
2 TL Backpulver
und als Geschmack kommen hier noch die Hitschies mit rein.
Dafür habe ich jetzt schon einmal
3 Tortenringe in 14,5 cm Durchmesser eingestellt
und mit Backpapier eingeschlagen,
weil der Teig auch relativ flüssig wird.
Dieser Teig wird zubereitet wie der Schokoteig,
d.h., die Eier werden mit
Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt 10-15 Min. cremig verrührt.
Buttermilch und Öl kommen dann langsam dazu.
Das Mehl wird mit dem Backpulver dazu gesiebt
und die Hitschies werde ich dann noch fein hacken
und einfach mit unterheben.
Und die 3 Böden werden dann auch schön im Ofen gebacken.
[Musik]
Danach sind die Böden fertig und es geht mit der Füllung weiter.
Die Schokoladen Torte bekommt jetzt eine ganz besondere Füllung,
nämlich den Mississippi Mud Pie.
Das ist einer der leckersten Schokoladenkuchen,
die ich je gebacken habe
Ich lasse praktisch den Mürbteigboden weg
und nehme einfach die Füllung, die dann da mit reinkommt.
In der Art habe ich es noch nie gemacht.
Also ich habe noch nie eine Torte damit gefüllt,
aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen.
Daher habe ich jetzt hier schon mal die Zutaten.
Ich brauche dafür 220 g Butter, 300 g Zartbitterschokolade,
450 g Sahne, etwas Vanilleextrakt, 45 g Kakao, 40 g Mehl und 6 Eier.
Dafür schmelze ich jetzt die Butter.
Ihr könnt das Ganze im Topf oder in der Mikrowelle machen,
bei niedriger Stufe, damit sie nicht anfängt zu spritzen.
Dann könnt ihr den Herd ausschalten
und die Schokolade in der Restwärme schmelzen
und anschließend die Sahne langsam dazu gießen.
Jetzt schmecke ich das Ganze noch mit Vanilleextrakt ab,
rühre dann noch Kakao und Mehl dazu
und dann kommt jedes Ei einzeln hinein,
bis eine schöne sämige Masse entsteht.
[Musik]
Diese Masse fülle ich jetzt in 2 Backringe,
die ich auf 24 cm Durchmesser eingestellt habe,
also ein bisschen kleiner als die Torte,
und habe sie auch mit Backpapier eingeschlagen.
Die werden jetzt gleich gleichzeitig bei Heißluft gebacken.
Dann kümmere ich mich um die Fruchteinlage für die mittlere Torte.
[Musik]
Für die Fruchteinlage nehme ich 1 kg gefrorene Früchte.
Ihr könnt auch frische Früchte nehmen,
aber die gefrorenen habe ich immer auf Vorrat da.
Ich habe hier einen Mix aus Himbeeren, Kirschen und Erdbeeren
und dazu nehme ich 2 Päckchen Agar Agar.
Das ist ein pflanzliches Geliermittel.
Die Früchte habe ich schon ein bisschen auftauen lassen,
werde sie pürieren und dann mit dem Agar Agar aufkochen.
[Musik]
Bei mir waren die Früchte jetzt noch nicht ganz aufgetaut.
Deswegen ging es ein bisschen langsamer.
Aber wenn sie aufgetaut sind, geht das auf jeden Fall besser.
Und jetzt kommt sie direkt in den Topf.
[Musik]
Ich sehe mich schon rufen, wenn das jetzt gleich aufblubbert,
dass ich sage mal hätten größeren Topf nehmen können.
Deswegen nehme ich lieber gleich einen größeren Topf,
um Katastrophen auszuschließen.
Wichtig ist nämlich, dass bei dieser Masse
- das ist nämlich anders als bei Gelatine -
diese Masse mit Agar Agar muss aufkochen
und 2 Min. lang richtig sprudelnd kochen.
Und dafür braucht sie natürlich Platz im Topf.
Das ist besser. Es ist besser.
Hier bin ich schon sehr penibel und stelle mir auch immer den Wecker,
damit es wirklich mindestens 2 Min. lang kocht.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr wollt,
könnt ihr das Ganze dann noch mit Vanilleextrakt verfeinern
oder mit Tonka Wonka.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier mal 5 Teller für die Fruchteinlage vorbereitet.
Ich braucht einfach etwas, was kleiner ist als der Tortendurchmesser,
also kleiner als 19 cm am besten.
Ich nehme dafür gerne tiefe Teller,
statte sie mit ein bisschen Frischhaltefolie aus,
damit das Ganze einfach nicht am Teller festklebt.
Und jetzt schön verteilen,
bei Zimmertemperatur fest werden lassen und dann einfrieren.
Das ist wichtig, dass die eingefroren werden,
damit ich sie später auch auf die Torte drauf bewegen kann.
So habe ich einfach den Vorteil,
dass ich eine Torte fruchtig hinbekomme.
Und die Fruchteinlage hält ja auch ein bisschen länger,
also besser als jetzt frische Früchte wie Erdbeeren und Himbeeren.
Die fallen ja gerne mal zusammen, werden matschig,
werden auch gerne mal sauer in so einer Torte.
So eine Fruchteinlage kann ich zum einen auf Vorrat herstellen
und einfach eingefroren lassen.
Also ich könnte jetzt auch 20 davon machen
und habe sie immer im Tiefkühlfach bereit.
Und ich habe eben auch den Vorteil,
dass es dann in der gefüllten Torte einfach länger hält.
Dann kann ich so eine Torte auch mal 3-4 Tage im Voraus herstellen.
Und das ergibt ja bei einer Hochzeitstorte schon Sinn.
[Musik]
Um zu checken, ob eine Fruchteinlage fest wird,
könnt ihr auch immer in einem kleinen Schälchen
eine kleine Gelierprobe machen,
natürlich bevor ihr das Ganze abfüllt.
Wenn die Gelierprobe dann innerhalb von 1-2 Min.
im Kühlschrank oder Gefrierfach fest wird,
dann ist sie perfekt.
Also so wie jetzt hier.
Ich kann schauen: Sie ist schön fest.
QED = Quod erat demonstrandum.
Das weiß man als aufmerksamer Mathematikschüler,
auch wenn man kein Latein hatte.
Ich hatte Französisch - war auch gut.
Très Bien!
Ach so, was ich noch sagen wollte:
Für heute reicht es mit dem Tortenbacken.
Ich hab jetzt nämlich alle Böden fertig.
Die sind jetzt alle abgekühlt, werden verpackt
und kommen in den Kühlschrank.
Mississippi Mud Pie kommt auch verpackt in den Kühlschrank.
Die Fruchteinlagen kommen ins Gefrierfach.
Ich glaube, ich werde noch eine Ganache herstellen,
dass die schon mal bereit ist für morgen.
Aber dazu findet ihr das Grundrezept schon auf meinem Kanal.
Das muss ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen,
Denn eine Ganache ist einfach nur Sahne aufkochen,
Schokolade rein, umrühren und fertig.
Die werde ich dann als einzige bei Raumtemperatur lagern.
Und dann machen wir morgen weiter mit der Torte.
Ein neuer Tag
und jetzt gibt's die Torte Füllungen.
Ich habe gestern tatsächlich keine Ganache mehr gemacht,
aber zu meinem Entsetzen habe ich gestern Abend
beim Rezeptschreiben festgestellt:
Ich habe im Mississippi Mud Pie den Zucker vergessen.
Eigentlich gehören da 300 g Zucker rein
und ich habe einfach 300 g Zucker vergessen.
Ist aber nicht schlimm;
wir probieren gleich die Masse.
Und ja, mein Gott, entweder schmeckt es richtig gut
oder schmeckt zu wenig süß,
Aber ich glaube, die Torte gleicht es ganz gut aus.
Ich gebe euch dann später beim Probieren das Feedback.
Jetzt mache ich einmal die Ganache.
Normalerweise hätte ich jetzt auch gerne
für die unterste Torte eine Schoko-Buttercreme gemacht,
denn eine Schoko-Buttercreme ist ein bisschen leichter als eine Ganache.
aber die Torte soll ja auch schön stabil sein
und eben das Gewicht der anderen Torten aushalten können.
Daher eine Ganache,
aber keine zum Bestreichen von Torten, sondern eine zum Befüllen
und die ist schon ein bisschen leichter.
Dafür gebe ich jetzt einfach die Sahne in den Topf,
lasse sie aufkochen und schmelze dann die Schokolade darin.
Da ist einfach das Verhältnis von Schokolade zu Sahne ein etwas anderes.
Während die Sahne noch für die Ganache aufkocht,
kann ich mich schon einmal um die Buttercreme kümmern
- für die anderen zwei Torten.
Da mache ich jetzt eine französische Buttercreme.
Die besteht aus Eiern, Zucker und Butter
und noch weiteren Zutaten wie Vanille und Salz.
Ich werde die eine Buttercreme dann mit Frucht verfeinern
und die andere noch einmal mit Hitschies.
Ursprünglich wollte ich eine Swiss Meringue Buttercream machen.
Die besteht nur aus Eiweiß,
aber dann habe ich so viel Eigelb übrig.
Deswegen mache ich die jetzt für die Füllung
und die schweizer wahrscheinlich für außenherum,
damit die ein bisschen heller und weißer ist.
Wichtig ist hier einfach nur,
dass das Ei mit dem Zucker verrührt und pasteurisiert wird,
d.h., bei 70°C 10 Min. erwärmen und schön verrühren.
Wenn ihr keine Küchenmaschine mit Hitzefunktion habt,
Macht ihr das einfach auf dem Herd:
Einfach ein Wasserbad aufstellen,
das Wasser aufkochen lassen und dann 10 Min. lang schön rühren
und dann ist es im Prinzip derselbe Effekt.
Nach dem Warmrühren wird sie auf jeden Fall
dann wieder 20 Min. kalt gerührt.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier schon einmal alle Tortenböden herausgelöst
und schneide sie einmal in der Mitte durch.
Es geht auch echt immer am besten,
wenn die Tortenböden über eine Nacht im Kühlschrank waren.
Bei dem hier ist was richtig Besonderes.
Josh, riech mal!
Der riecht richtig nach Bubble Gum.
JOSH: Richtiger Kaugummikuchen.
SALLY: Oh, richtig was für Kinder.
Doch, der ist echt gut.
So, dann habe ich die jetzt nämlich vorbereitet.
Nun kann ich die Buttercreme fertigstellen.
Die Eiercreme ist jetzt schön runter gekühlt.
Die Butter habe ich schon verrührt.
Jetzt habe ich hier einen Teil Früchte.
Da hab ich einfach tiefgefrorene Früchte
ganz lange einkochen lassen und püriert,
damit so eine richtig schöne dickflüssige Konsistenz entsteht.
Damit kann ich nämlich jetzt die Frucht-Buttercreme zubereiten
Und für die andere Buttercreme habe ich hier noch einmal diese Bubble Gum Hitschies.
Hier ist jetzt einfach wichtig,
dass die Eiercreme wieder heruntergekühlt ist,
damit die Butter nicht schmilzt.
Ich tausche ganz kurz die Schüssel.
Hier kommt die Butter rein
und dann kann ich die Eiercreme hier vorsichtig rein rühren
und das Ganze schön luftig aufschlagen.
Wenn man Buttercreme schön lange rührt,
dann schmeckt sie auch nicht nach Butter,
sondern einfach richtig schön cremig
und nach dem, was ihr später dazugebt
- in meinem Fall dann Frucht oder eben diese Bubble Gums oder Schokolade
oder ihr könnt auch Amaretto oder andere Liköre dazugeben.
Das ist schon echt lecker.
[Musik]
Dann wiege ich jetzt die Buttercreme ab
und teile sie auf: zwei Drittel, ein Drittel.
Zwei Drittel für die große Torte, ein Drittel für die kleine.
Falls ihr die Torten einzeln nachmachen wollt,
gebe ich euch die Rezepte auf jeden Fall einzeln an,
denn dann ist es einfacher zum Nachmachen.
[Musik]
Die große Menge Creme wird jetzt mit dem Fruchtpüree verrührt.
Wie gesagt, eine schöne dickflüssige Konsistenz.
[Musik]
Ich fülle sie mir jetzt nur kurz um,
damit ich gleich leichter damit arbeiten kann.
Ich habe mal auf einer Hochzeit ein richtig großes Kompliment bekommen,
für meine Hochzeitstorte,
und zwar vom Hochzeitsfotografen.
Er hat gesagt, er fotografiert seit über 20 Jahren Hochzeiten.
Und meine Hochzeitstorte war die erste Torte,
die er aufgegessen hat, weil er gesagt hat:
Die hat geschmeckt.
Die sah nicht nur gut aus; sie hat geschmeckt.
Ich finde es auch immer wichtig, dass Hochzeitstorten gut schmecken,
weil die meisten gehen schon immer recht viel auf die Optik.
Ich finde es einfach extrem schwierig,
immer einen guten Geschmack reinzubringen und.
dass sie trotzdem so schön aussieht,
weil oft hat man es ja so,
dass man so eine leichte Creme haben will.
- keine Ahnung, z.B. Mango-Maracuja-Mus.
Und sowas ist immer schwierig,
in Torten, die gestapelt werden,
aber dann immer so das perfekte Verhältnis
zwischen Optik und Geschmack hinkriegen,
ist schon nicht so ganz leicht.
Deswegen mache ich mir immer den mega Aufwand mit
den verschiedenen Schichten und allem.
Aber ihr könnt ja mal schreiben, ob es euch da auch so geht,
ob ihr schon einmal eine richtig leckere Hochzeitstorte gegessen habt
Und was vielleicht auch die schlimmste Torte war.
Und was für euch für so eine Hochzeitstorte das Wichtigste ist:
eher Geschmack oder eher Optik?
Ich bin da… Ich bin immer so…
Ich finde, es muss beides passen.
Naja, wäre ja langweilig.
Gut! Die kleine cremen fülle ich jetzt einfach hier rein.
Hier kommen die Bubble Gum Hitschies rein
und das ist die Kinder-Creme.
Ich habe kurz überlegt,
ob ich die Drachenzungen mit rein schmelze,
dass ich eine blaue Creme habe,
aber ich finde,
die passt dann optisch doch nicht mehr so gut zur Hochzeitstorte.
Deswegen reicht das so.
Aber ansonsten könnt ihr wirklich
diese blauen Drachenzungen mit rein schmelzen
und z.B. ein bisschen Sahne auflösen.
Dann gibt es da die blaue Farbe ab.
Das dann schon nochmal…
Für eine Kindertorte mach ich das mal.
Ok, kurz aufräumen und dann geht es ans Füllen der zwei kleinen Torten.
Los geht es mit dem Füllen.
Ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal einen schönen flachen Boden.
Ich drehe ihn jetzt aber einmal um,
denn beim Backen sind die Süßigkeiten auf dem Boden
und deswegen ist es hier so ein bisschen klebrig.
Das macht aber gar nichts in der Torte;
da passt nämlich perfekt.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier bei der kleinen Torte
einfach die Bubble Gum Buttercreme und schichte sie.
Da würde ich jetzt auch gar nicht großartig mehr dazu machen.
Das ist ja praktisch schon vom Geschmack her ideal.
Jetzt einfach darauf achten, dass die Füllung schön glatt ist.
Dann kommt der nächste Boden drauf
und so brauche ich jetzt alle 6 Böden auf.
Wenn euch die Torte zu warm ist
oder es im Raum zu warm ist
und ihr merkt, die lässt sich nicht gut füllen,
dann einfach kurz kühl stellen,
ein paar Minuten warten und dann weiter füllen.
[Musik]
Der Trend geht zu hohen Torte.
Ich sag's euch, das ist einfach schön.
[Musik]
Puh, Torte 1 ist gefüllt und kann in den Kühlschrank.
Um die Torte zu stabilisieren,
setze ich aber noch einmal den Tortenring drumherum.
Dann ist sie schön fest.
Dann kann ich sie abdecken und kühlen.
Los geht's zur Torte 2.
[Musik]
Okay. Los geht's zur zweiten Torte.
Da passt es jetzt auch mit dem Ganaching Board,
denn ich hab ja gestern die Biskuitböden ein bisschen kleiner gemacht
- aus folgendem Grund:
Ich hab jetzt nämlich hier praktisch ringsherum einen kleinen Rand,
den ich später zum Glattstreichen der Torte benutzen werde,
aber da kommen wir später erst dazu.
Ich muss jetzt erst noch zwei Torten füllen.
Okay. Jetzt hab ich hier die Buttercreme.
Da kommt jetzt erst einmal nur eine dünne Schicht drauf.
Okay, wenn ich dünn sage, meine ich auch dünn. [Lacht]
Und die Mitte schön flach,
denn hier kommt jetzt die Fruchteinlage rein.
Die sollte jetzt auf jeden Fall gefroren sein,
denn ansonsten kriegt man sie einfach nicht so gut rüber bewegt.
Dann kann sie euch durchbrechen und das wollen wir ja jetzt auch nicht.
Hier ist einfach wichtig,
dass die praktisch ein bisschen kleiner ist als die Torte selbst.
Da kommt jetzt Creme drauf
und mit der Creme praktisch wieder schön glatt streichen.
Da ist jetzt der Vorteil, dass die Fruchteinlage gefroren ist.
Dann wird auch die Creme schön fest
und die Torte lässt sich einfach wundervoll stapeln.
Wenn ihr das freie Stapeln nicht so hinbekommt,
dann nehmt einfach direkt schon einen Tortenring.
Dann bekommt ihr auf jeden Fall auch auf die Höhe
eine schöne gerade Torte hin.
Aber ich mache es gerne so frei,
damit ihr einfach schön reinschauen könnt.
[Musik]
Gut, Torte Nummer 2.
Okay, die ist nicht so ganz perfekt, aber das wird!
Die drücken wir zusammen. [Lacht]
Was ist da passiert? [Lacht]
Egal, das wird gleich.
[Musik]
Puh, Torte Nummer 2 ist gefüllt und jetzt hoffe ich,
dass die Ganache schon richtig schön kalt ist.
Die habe ich jetzt diesmal ausnahmsweise im Kühlschrank,
weil es eben eine Ganache zum Befüllen ist und nicht zum Bestreichen
- die darf in den Kühlschrank
und wird noch mit dem Handrührgerät aufgeschlagen.
JOSH: Warum isst du denn da Müsli?
[Sally lacht]
Sollte das nicht in die Torte?
SALLY: Ist das in der Torte?
Dann kommt da jetzt Milch drauf und ich esse das Müsli.
Ich würde sagen, wir packen Müsli in die Schokotorte.
Jetzt geht's an die…
Ich würde gerne sagen „zuckerfreie Torte",
aber nein, sie ist nicht zuckerfrei.
Aber der Mississippi Mud Pie ist fast zuckerfrei.
Diese 2 Böden werde ich jetzt auf einmal durchschneiden,
dass es 4 sind.
Ich muss echt sagen, wenn man einen Tag vorher alle Böden backt
und die Füllungen vorbereitet
und dann am nächsten Tag die Torten zusammensetzt,
finde ich es so vom Zeitmanagement her immer am besten.
Da kommt man einfach nicht in Stress
und gerade das Vorbacken und Vorbereiten nimmt so viel Zeit in Anspruch.
Und dann die Kühlzeit, die man dann noch zu beachten hat…
Es ist schon…
Ja, schon gut, wenn man es sich gut vorbereitet.
Und in der Zeit, wo man eben eine Wartezeit hat,
kann man nämlich z.B. schon einmal Deko vorbereiten,
Blüten oder Figuren oder einfach chillen
- das geht auch.
Gut, 4 Böden…
Dann wird jetzt die kalte Schokoladencreme einmal aufgeschlagen.
[Musik]
Okay, jetzt kommt hier ein bisschen Cremen drauf.
Eine Schoko-Ganache ist schon lecker.
Mich ärgert es gerade ein bisschen,
dass ich nicht die Callebaut Schokolade benutzt habe.
Irgendwie war ich mit dieser dunklen Schokolade in meinem alten Trott.
Naja, das nächste Mal nehme ich die Kuvertüre-Chips,
weil die schon richtig lecker sind.
Okay, eine dünne Schicht Creme …
Darauf kommt der ungezuckerte Mississippi Mud Pie.
Oh, so!
Darauf…
Das wird die Torte für Marcel:
so Schokolade in Schokolade gefüllt mit Schokolade. [Lacht]
Um hier jetzt Crunch reinzubringen,
habe ich hier Salzbrezeln.
Die sind in Kuvertüre getaucht und fein gehackt.
Die kommen da mit rein.
[Musik]
So, wieder ein bisschen glätten.
Dann der nächste Boden und das fülle ich jetzt einfach so.
Ich habe jetzt nur 2 Mississippi Mud Pie-Schichten,
aber ich glaube, das reicht auch.
Ansonsten wird das glaub ich ein bisschen zu mächtig.
Ich meine, so eine große Torte
schneidet man dann schon auch in mehr als 12 Stücke.
[Musik]
Ich habe gestern einen großen Fehler begangen.
Ich wollt eigentlich 3 Mississippi-Böden machen und jetzt habe ich nur 2
- warum auch immer…
Und jetzt ist es nicht so symmetrisch.
Also werde ich jetzt die Torte kühlen,
werde noch einmal die Hälfte des Mississippis machen,
auch ohne Zucker, dass es so wird wie dieser
Dann kommt es hier noch drauf und dann wird die Torte fertig gefüllt,
denn so kann ich das nicht lassen.
Da bin ich…
Da ist mein Auge zu Symmetrie geschult.
[Musik]
So schön! Wow, wow, wow, wow!
Ich glaube,
das wird die neue Lieblings-Schokoladentorte von einigen hier.
JOSH: Ja!
SALLY: Ich würde sagen: Ring drum und ab die Kühlung!
Eine Torte, die mit Mississippi Mud Pie gefüllt ist!
Also besser geht es echt nicht.
[Rewind]
JOSH: Halt, halt, halt, halt! Du hast die Crunch-Schicht vergessen.
SALLY: Ja!
[Sally räuspert]
Eine Torte gefüllt mit Mississippi Mud Pie und Salzbrezeln
- besser geht es nicht! [Lacht]
Wieso bin ich gerade so vergesslich?
Ich sage's euch, wieso…
Ich…
Ich habe meinen Kopf einfach überall:
Ich habe meinen Kopf bei den Figuren,
bei der Torte,
bei den Blüten.
Es ist einfach… Ja.
Ich wollte kurz romantisch sein und sagen
„Ich habe mich neu in Murat verliebt",
Aber dann dachte ich so „Nein, der ist auch nie romantisch". [Lacht]
Jetzt aber!
Die Torten sind jetzt schön kalt und ich habe hier schon einmal
eine Swiss Meringue Buttercreme vorbereitet.
Ich habe schon eine richtig große Menge,
weil ich einfach glaube,
dass ich die Menge für die 3 Torten brauche.
Daher reicht leider die Küchenmaschine nicht mehr aus
und ich muss das Ganze hier noch
in einer extra großen Schüssel verrühren. [Lacht]
Ich dachte mir so:
Okay, wenn mir etwas übrig haben, haben wir eben was übrig.
Aber Hauptsache ich mache die Creme nur einmal,
denn mir passiert das relativ oft.
- nein, eigentlich nicht so oft -
aber passiert es schon ab und zu mal,
dass ich dann doch zu wenig Creme habe
und deswegen habe ich lieber vorgesorgt.
Ja, das ist alles Butter,
falls ihr euch das fragt - mit Puderzucker.
Ich denke mir gerade so,
man hätte noch eine größere Schüssel nehmen können, aber es gibt keine.
Und das hier ist die Eiweißmasse.
[Musik]
Ich habe so die leise Vermutung,
dass das Handrührgerät dafür nicht ausreicht.
Also muss „der Gerät" per Hand rühren.
[Musik]
Siamak, ich habe 12 Liter Buttercreme für dich.
Komm und hol sie dir.
Ich habe noch nie so viel Buttercreme auf einmal gemacht.
Ja, ich portionieren mir das jetzt ein bisschen.
und streiche die Torten damit ein.
Ich starte jetzt hier einmal mit der mittleren Torte.
Zuerst geht es jetzt darum, diese Lücken mit der Creme aufzufüllen.
Ich habe jetzt die restliche Creme einfach kaltgestellt.
Die Lücken füllt ihr einfach erst einmal so auf
und achtet jetzt auch drauf,
dass ihr eine Schüssel mit Buttercreme habt,
die praktisch schmutzig werden kann
- also im Sinne von:
Da dürfen auch Kuchenbrösel rein.
Die restliche Buttercreme muss aber schneeweiß bleiben,
weil ich da jetzt keine Fondant Schicht draufmache,
sondern die Buttercreme ist der Abschluss der Torte
und daher muss dann da die Torte schön weiß bleiben.
Die erste Schicht findet im Prinzip alle Krümel
und deckt diese Lücken ab und ist sozusagen die Grundierung.
[Musik]
Dann kommt die Torte mit der Grundierung erst einmal in den Kühlschrank,
bis die erste Schicht fest geworden ist.
[Musik]
Dann könnt ihr hier immer auch schon schön
den Rest mit einer Teigkarte abziehen.
[Musik]
Da bietet es sich echt immer an,
erst einmal alle Torten zu grundieren.
In der Zeit ist die erste wieder kalt
und ich kann dann daran schön weiterarbeiten.
[Musik]
Wow! Grundieren, die dritte.
Ich sage es euch,
Ich werde noch zur Hochzeitstortenkonditorin.
Nein!
Jetzt geht es ans Glattstreichen.
Die Buttercreme sollte immer eine schön cremige Konsistenz haben:
nicht zu weich, nicht zu fest!
Falls sie mal zu weich ist,
könnt ihr sie kurz in Kühlschrank stellen.
Falls sie zu fest ist,
könnt ihr sie auch kurz über das warme Wasserbad stellen
und einfach immer wieder aufschlagen.
Das klappt ganz gut.
Ich glätte jetzt erst einmal kurz die Oberfläche.
Da bietet sich ein Drehteller schon an, muss ich sagen.
Das ist dann etwas praktischer als ohne,
weil man es dann eben praktisch ohne Absatz schön glatt bekommt.
Jetzt kommt hier das zweite Ganaching Board in der gleichen Größe drauf.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr praktisch die Lücken hier mit der Creme auffüllen.
Und dann die Teigkarte hier glatt ansetzen und einmal abziehen.
[Musik]
Dann seht ihr jetzt hier noch die Lücken
und die füllt ihr jetzt noch einmal auf.
[Musik]
Ihr seht hier:
Je besser die Lücken gefüllt werden, umso glatter wird die Torte.
Ich stelle sie jetzt gleich zwischendurch noch einmal kalt
und kann dann zum Abschluss eine letzte Schicht draufmachen
und dann ist sie einfach perfekt.
[Musik]
Die große Torte hat jetzt noch kein Ganaching Board drunter.
Das hab ich irgendwie vergessen.
Deswegen muss ich das jetzt kurz Upside-down machen.
D.h., ein Ganaching Board drauf
und die Torte einmal komplett umdrehen.
[Musik]
Oh Gott, sie rutscht! [Atmet mehrmals auf]
Geht!
Es ist zwar riskant, aber es geht.
Dann kann sie jetzt auch glatt gemacht werden.
[Musik]
Okay, jetzt kommt die Torte auch über Nacht Kühlschrank.
Alle 3 dürfen kühlen.
Die Creme hebe ich natürlich auch noch auf.
Die kommt auch in Kühlschrank
und wird morgen einfach kurz noch einmal aufgeschlagen.
Dann kann ich die Torten fertig glatt streichen.
Beim Tortenbacken ist es echt ganz wichtig, dass man geduldig ist.
Wenn ich die jetzt zu kurz kühle,
dann verformt sie sich die ganze Zeit und das möchte ich nicht.
Deswegen einmal gut durchkühlen.
Ihr könnt hier noch einmal eine Tortenrandfolie drumherum legen,
damit einfach die Torte auch ein bisschen geschützt ist.
Hände waschen!
Los geht's mit der Torte.
Ich drehe sie jetzt einmal um, denn wenn ich die Torte später staple,
dann wird das Ganaching Board nicht mehr dabei sein,
sondern ich werde ein Cake Board drunter setzen.
Deswegen muss ich hier das untere Ganaching Board
jetzt schon einmal abnehmen.
Das geht mit einem ganz flachen Messer ganz gut.
Wenn ihr es vorher erwärmt, dann löst sich das wunderbar.
Dann ein wenig Buttercreme auf den Boden,
als Kleber sozusagen.
Dann ein 20 cm Cake Board drunter.
Jetzt kann ich es wieder umdrehen
und dieses Cake Board bleibt dann praktisch unter der Torte
und ist so ein bisschen eine Stapelhilfe.
[Musik]
Hier ist es jetzt auch noch wichtig,
dass das Cake Board auch nicht mehr sichtbar ist.
D.h., den Rest überdecke ich jetzt noch einmal mit ein bisschen Creme.
Ihr könnt auch beim Einstreichen mit der Ganache
einfach unten drunter schon mal das Cake Board nehmen
Und oben nur ein Garching Board.
Da habe ich aber gestern nicht sofort mitgedacht.
Dann hätte ich mir jetzt den Schritt gespart.
[Musik]
So, dann könnt ihr jetzt hier die Oberfläche noch glätten.
Ja, theoretisch kann man die Torte natürlich auch
mit dem Ganaching Board einfach stapeln,
aber das Ganaching Board ist doch relativ glatt
und da hätte ich schon Angst, dass es ein bisschen verrutscht
- gerade beim Stapeln der Torte.
Deswegen nehme ich lieber diese Cake Boards.
Die sind so ein bisschen matter und halten einfach besser.
Man könnte jetzt im Prinzip einfach die Oberfläche glätten, kurz kühlen,
den Rand nochmal säubern und dann ist die Torte fertig.
Man macht beim Backen mit so viel Creme und Buttercreme Fondant
schon immer so eine kleine Butterkur auf der Haut,
weil man am Abend immer so voll mit Buttercreme ist.
Es ist schon immer riskant bei so einer schweren Torte
ein Flip-over zu machen…
Eins, zwei, drei!
Boah!
… weil die dann immer so kurz rutscht.
[Musik]
Vielleicht kennt ihr da ja noch einen Trick,
wie man die Ganaching Boards einfach weg bekommt.
Also ich mache das Messer einfach immer ein bisschen warm.
Ich weiß, dass viele mit Folie drunter arbeiten,
aber das finde ich dann…
Dann kann man es sich auch gleich sparen.
Denn die Kunst ist natürlich,
beim Ablösen des Boards nicht allzu viel Torte zu beschädigen.
[Musik]
Wie hier…
Ich muss da echt eins sagen:
Ich liebe ja das Tortenbacken
und ich liebe es auch mal so eine Hochzeitstorte zuzubereiten,
aber jede Woche könnte ich es nicht.
Das ist mir echt zu aufwendig, weil:
Überlegt mal:
Ich bin seit 3 Tagen dran die Torte zu backen, zu füllen,
Geschmack reinzubringen und die Grundform hinzubekommen.
Wenn ich jetzt eine Fondant-Torte machen wollen würde,
hätte ich ja noch einmal den Deko-Part.
Und das ist schon sehr aufwendig.
Also echt Hut ab,
vor allem, die das hauptberuflich machen
und für Hochzeiten, dann noch den Hochzeitsstress haben,
für einen bestimmten Termin die Torte machen müssen.
Das ist schon nicht so easy.
Wenn ich da so an die Heike denke…
Sie hat ihren eigenen Backshop sozusagen
und macht da eben Hochzeitstorten;
Sweet Table; „Suess & Salzig" heißt sie.
Sie ist in Ulm.
Sie macht es dann schon jede Woche zur Hochzeitssaison.
Sie macht des hammermäßig:
eine Hochzeitstorte, dann noch viele Cupcakes dazu, Desserts, Macarons
und ich glaube, sie macht das ganz allein.
Das ist schon…
Hut ab!
Aber die Hochzeitsgäste und die Hochzeitspaare freuen sich immer.
Gut, man muss auch sagen:
Der Stress ist ein etwas anderer,
wenn man das dann noch vor der Kamera macht,
denn dann beobachtet ihr mich immer dabei.
[Musik]
So kommt sie jetzt erst einmal in die Kühlung.
Was wiegt sie?
Bei der kleinsten Torte habe ich jetzt kein Cake Board,
das klein genug ist.
Deswegen hab ich hier einfach ein Stück Pappe laminiert.
Es muss einfach etwas sein, das nicht aufweicht
und stabil genug ist,
damit die Torte einfach so ein bisschen einen Stand hat.
Die wird nämlich später mit Tortendübeln befestigt
und braucht einen flachen Untergrund.
Aber guckt, so kann man sich helfen.
[Musik]
Ah schön.
Ich finde, das ist echt eine schöne Tortengröße
und ich mag es, wenn die Torten so schmal und so hoch sind,
so wie der Josh. [Lacht]
Ich bin tatsächlich ein Fan davon,
wenn die Torten nicht ganz glatt sind,
wenn sie so ein bisschen wie meine Wand…
so etwas wie Spachtelmasse haben.
Deswegen mache ich vielleicht später noch ein
bisschen Spachtel außenherum.
Ach, jetzt kommt sie auch erst einmal in den Kühlschrank
und ich kümmere mich derweil um die Deko.
Ich zeig euch jetzt, wie ihr aus eckigen Backoblaten,
also Esspapier, Blumen herstellen könnt.
Diese Blumen könnt ihr dann für die Torte als Dekoration verwenden.
Und zwar mach ich jetzt erst einmal so eine Art Rose.
Ich habe jetzt dafür hier 3 verschieden große Rosenausstecher.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr euch mit einem Lebensmittelstift
zuerst einmal ein Blatt vorzeichnen,
dieses dann ausschneiden und als Schablone verwenden,
um weitere Blätter auszuschneiden.
Damit das Ausschneiden schneller geht,
könnt ihr auch 2, 3 Esspapierbögen übereinander legen,
dann die Schablone drauf und drumherum schneiden.
[Esspapiergeräusche]
[Musik]
Und die Reste, die ihr habt, auf jeden Fall aufheben.
Das brauche ich nämlich später als Kleber
und ich habe jetzt hier einmal die größte Rosengröße
und dann mache ich mir noch die zwei kleineren.
[Musik]
Als Nächstes geht es darum diese Blätter sozusagen anzufeuchten.
Viele machen das so,
dass sie es praktisch über dampfendes Wasser halten,
also über kochendes Wasser.
Ich mache es nicht so.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen Rosenwasser,
gebe da auch Farbe dazu.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch neutral und weiß lassen.
Aber bei mir wird jetzt ja auch eine Bollywood-Torte,
eine Hochzeitstorte - ein bisschen Farbe darf da schon sein.
Daher nehme ich jetzt hier einfach Lebensmittelfarbpulver,
ganz wenig nur!
Dann einen schönen breiten Pinsel.
Dann kann ich die Blätter beidseitig bestreichen,
um sie aufzuweichen.
Ich habe jetzt hier zwei Silikonprägestempel für Rosenblätter.
Die teste ich jetzt auch aus.
Da streue ich so ein bisschen Bäckerstärke drauf,
lege das Blatt hinein
und damit kann ich so ein bisschen strukturieren.
Dann werden die Blätter getrocknet
über z.B. Eierbechern oder in Esslöffeln drin.
Da könnt ihr einfach schauen,
was so ein bisschen eine bauchige runde Form hat.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr die Blüten dann soweit fertig habt,
lasst ihr sie trocknen,
entweder ganz normal bei Raumtemperatur,
denn jetzt ist ja praktisch die Feuchtigkeit des Rosenwassers drauf.
Ihr könnt aber auch ganz normales Wasser
oder auch einen Alkohol nehmen, der auch schnell verfliegt.
Oder ihr trocknet es im Dörrautomaten
bei der niedrigsten Temperatureinstellung,
bei 30°C für ungefähr 1 Stunde.
Dann sollte die ganze Feuchtigkeit weg
und die Blätter richtig schön fest sein.
Was ich in der Zwischenzeit machen werde:
Ich zerkleinere hier diese Reste,
zerdrücke sie so ein bisschen mit Wasser
und schmelze das Ganze in der Mikrowelle.
Dann ist das praktisch mein Kleber,
den ich gleich zum Zusammenkleben der Blüten verwende.
[Musik]
So sehen die Blütenblätter jetzt aus.
Also es ist echt Wahnsinn, wenn man das so hört,
wie trocken die jetzt auch geworden sind.
Hier ist auch diese Masse, die ich in der Mikrowelle erwärmt habe.
Jetzt setzt ihr das praktisch einfach zusammen.
Außen die großen Blätter und dann immer kleiner
und am Ende sieht die Blüte dann so aus.
Also schon sehr schön!
JOSH: Ist die etwa echt?
SALLY: Die ist echt aus Esspapier.
D.h., ihr startet außen mit einem Blatt.
Dann nehme ich mir einen Pinsel.
Das ist echt ein richtig cooler Kleber.
Er riecht so ein bisschen nach Babybrei.
Ich finde es lecker.
Das kommt hier so rein.
Dann die nächste Blüte, wieder essbaren Kleber.
Einfach wie Kleister.
Nächste Blüte.
So setze ich jetzt erst einmal 5 Stück ineinander.
Was ich an dem so toll finde:
Die sind zwar schön trocken,
aber nicht so wirklich brüchig, wie z.B. Blütenpaste.
Also ist es ein bisschen einfacher damit zu arbeiten.
Aber trotzdem schön vorsichtig sein!
So, unten hab ich jetzt 5.
Und dann geht's weiter.
Ich nehme jetzt noch einmal von der Größe
und dann nehme ich aber auch mal kleinere in der Mitte.
Jetzt seht ihr auch,
warum man sie in so kleine Förmchen reinlegt:
damit sie einfach so eine runde Form bekommen.
[Musik]
Zur Formgebung könnt ihr sie einfach in so eine Schale setzen.
Das muss dann natürlich auch noch einmal trocknen.
Ich mache es dann wieder im Dörrautomaten, damit es schneller geht.
Und wenn ihr habt oder irgendwie besorgen könnt,
dann könnt ihr noch so kleine Blütenpollen verwenden
- die sind jetzt natürlich nicht essbar,
aber ihr könnt auch einfach Perlen reinsetzen:
Zuckerperlen, bunte Perlen…
[Musik]
Jetzt wird die Hochzeitstorte zusammengesetzt.
Ich hab mich jetzt dazu entschlossen
eine flache Glasplatte zu nehmen,
weil die Torte doch relativ schwer ist.
Die ist so richtig schwer.
Und dann ist es mir zu riskant
- mit so einer Etagere mit Fuß.
Ja, muss ich auch einmal sagen:
So risikobereit bin ich dann auch nicht.
Jetzt werden die anderen Torte draufgesetzt.
Damit aber das Gewicht dieser Torten nicht die untere Torte zerstört,
braucht ihr so kleine Dübel.
D.h., einfach Rundhölzer oder z.B. Strohhalme nehmen,
die aber stabil sind.
Das ist schon sehr wichtig.
Die einmal kurz vorher ausmessen und in die Torte reindrücken.
Nicht so weit außen, denn da ist ja der Rand.
[Musik]
Die müssen natürlich vor dem Essen rausgenommen werden.
[Lacht]
Oh Leute, jetzt muss ich sie noch weiter rüberschieben.
[Musik]
Jetzt setze ich meine Blumen da dran.
Oh, die sind schon richtig schön.
Also die sind echt der Wahnsinn.
Ich mach hier so ein paar Blumen und hier.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt noch Blumen
von der Freundin von unserer Jutta.
Sie ist nämlich Floristin hier bei uns in Rheinsheim.
Da muss ich echt immer…
Also unterstützt die Floristen vor Ort und kauft dort eure Blumen.
Die sind jetzt aus Reinheim von Blumen Kuhn
- da haben wir sie her und es sind richtig schöne Blumen.
Ganz, ganz toll.
[Musik]
Ich habe hier jetzt noch diese Crispearls.
Das sind Kekse mit Schokolade überzogen.
Und diese ChocRocks.
Das sieht aus wie eine Zuckerdekoration,
ist aber eigentlich Schokolade,
schmeckt extrem gut und passt perfekt auf Torten.
Die gebe ich hier noch drauf, gerade nur so ein bisschen.
Und zum Fertigstellen der Torte Tom and Jerry.
Tadaaaa!
[Musik]
Die Hochzeitstage ist fertig
und die Hochzeitsgäste können jetzt zum Probieren kommen.
Hey! Stopp! Nein! Nicht hier bei der Torte!
Oh mein Gott!
Ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst!
Es ist nicht euer Ernst!
Habt ihr jetzt wirklich neben meiner Torte…
Die Torte ist einfach zerstört.
Tom, was soll denn das?
Jerry, was lachst du so?
Die Torte ist einfach kaputt.
Aber egal, Leute, egal!
Die Torte ist trotzdem lecker
und wir werden jetzt auch essen.
Und ich glaube, der Kinofilm ist wirklich der Wahnsinn
und ist bestimmt richtig, richtig lustig.
Ich weiß zumindest,
dass im Kinofilm die Hochzeitstorte auch zerstört wird.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch eine zweite.
Man weiß es nicht.
Normalerweise gibt es ja schon immer ein Happy End irgendwo.
Ich hoffe es zumindest sehr.
Für euch gibt es übrigens auch ein Happy End,
denn ihr bekommt auch was zu gewinnen.
Ihr wisst,
dass wir bei Kinokooperationen auch immer etwas für euch haben.
Und zwar könnt ihr 5x2 Kinotickets
und ein signiertes Buch von mir gewinnen,
wenn ihr unter dieses Video kommentiert,
was euch in diesem Video am besten gefallen hat.
Und vielleicht könnt ihr ja auch schreiben,
ob Tom und Jerry eure Kindheitshelden waren,
ob ihr als Kind auch immer gern die Serie geschaut habt
und wie ihr die beiden so findet.
Ich würde sagen, ich hole mein Team kurz zusammen.
Tom hat, glaube ich, die Torte schon probiert.
Schmeckt sie dir?
Ja? Gut.
Ich hole kurz mein Team zusammen und dann probieren wir die Torte.
oder zumindest das, was von der Torte noch übrig ist.
[Musik]
Wir haben ja jetzt keine 100 Hochzeitsgäste.
Deswegen setzen wir die Torte für den Anschnitt auseinander
und ihr dürft gerne zum Probieren kommen.
[Musik]
So schön.
SARAH: Danke schön! Willst du mitessen? [Alle lachen]
Oder willst du die nächste?
[Musik]
SALLY: Das sieht schon… !
Wow! Komm, wir probieren!
SARAH: Hey!
Hier, ich teile mit dir.
SALLY: Das ist die für Kinder? [Sally bejaht]
Das ist Team Schoko und das ist Team Frucht.
Ich finde es immer gut, wenn Torten eine Auswahl haben,
Also wenn man einfach für jeden was dabei hat,
SARAH: Weißt du, was ich daran richtig gut finde?
TOLGA: Dass sie nicht zu süß ist.
SARAH: Ja, und dass richtig viel, viel, viel Frucht drin ist
und nicht nur so eine Schicht.
Ich halt es, wenn du willst.
SALLY: Mmh!
SARAH: Hast du mir gerade das da weggenommen? Nein!
SALLY: Oh, lecker! Und ich hab doch hier den Zucker vergessen
- im Mississippi Mud Pie.
Aber ich finde es hammer.
Ich würde den immer so machen.
Ich würde das immer so machen.
Oh, schon eine leckere Hochzeitstorte.
TOLGA: Aber können wir mal bitte sagen, dass sie aussehen wie echt?
SALLY: Diese Blüten solltet ihr einfach einmal ausprobieren.
Ja! Ich wollte ja ursprünglich so ein Farbspiel machen.
so ein bisschen Bollywood-Style mit pink noch,
aber ich fand sie so dann schon schöner.
Also wir essen jetzt mal unsere Torte weiter.
Wie gesagt, denkt ans Gewinnspiel.
Ihr könnt 5x2 Kinotickets gewinnen für Tom und Jerry
und jeweils ein signiertes Buch von mir.
Kommentiert einfach unter dem Video,
Was euch an diesem Video am besten gefallen hat
und ob Tom und Jerry auch eure Kindheitshelden waren.
Falls ihr jetzt wissen wollt, wie die Tom-Figur entstanden ist,
dann schaut euch jetzt gerne noch das Video weiter an,
denn da steckt eine Rice Crispy Masse drin.
Ich mache noch ein Gewinnspiel:
Ihr könnt noch diese 3 Tortenetageren als 3er-Set gewinnen,
wenn ihr mir noch das Video kommentiert,
wie viele Eier ich für diese Torte gebraucht habe
- für Teig, für Creme, für Buttercreme usw.
Die Antwort findet ihr auf meinem Blog,
denn da habe ich ja das Rezept angelegt.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch die drei Tortenständer.
Ich bin gespannt.
[Musik]
Um Modelliermasse herzustellen, nehmt ihr einfach Fondant.
Das ist praktisch Zuckerüberzugsmasse und Blütenpaste
und vermischt das Ganze 1:1.
Dann habe ich nämlich eine Modelliermasse,
die schön fest wird; die Figuren können aushärten.
Aber wenn ich jetzt nur Blütenpaste nehmen würde,
wäre das Ganze zu fest und würde zu schnell aushärten.
Ich will auch daran wie mit Knete arbeiten können.
Jetzt werde ich mir erst einmal die Farbe mischen.
Ich fange jetzt einfach mal mit Tom, der Katze, an
und mische mir ein schönes Grau.
Dafür nehme ich einfach Schwarz, Weiß und die Blütenpaste.
Vielleicht gebe ich sogar noch ein wenig Blau dazu,
weil ich finde, dass es so ein Blaugrau ist.
Jetzt heißt es erst einmal kneten.
[Musik]
Die Farben sind jetzt gemischt und ihr könnt jetzt überlegen,
ob ihr die Figur zwei- oder dreidimensional machen wollt.
Ich hatte kurz überlegt, sie zweidimensional zu formen,
was auch recht cool aussieht.
Man kann sich dann nämlich einfach eine Schablone ausdrucken
und das Ganze hierauf formen.
Da habe ich auch schon verschiedene Videos dazu erstellt.
Ich werde jetzt allerdings doch einen 3D-Kopf von Tom herstellen.
Dafür benutze ich jetzt eine Rice Crispy Masse.
D.h., ich habe jetzt hier
zu gleichen Teilen Marshmallows und Rice Crispys.
Das sind diese Schoko Crispys,
die es zum Frühstück als Müsli gibt,
und noch ein bisschen Butter.
Jetzt kann ich erst einmal kurz
die Marshmallows in der Mikrowelle schmelzen,
falls ihr eine habt.
Wenn nicht,
geht es auch einfach auf dem Herd in einer beschichteten Pfanne.
Aber Mikrowelle ist schon einfacher.
[Musik]
Oh!
Die werden jetzt mit den Rice Crispys und der Butter
zu einer schönen, klebrigen Masse verrührt.
[Musik]
Jetzt am besten die Hände kurz fetten.
Vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Arbeitsplatte,
denn es wird klebrig.
Schön aufpassen, dass ihr euch nicht verbrennt.
Aber wenn ihr so ein bisschen mit dem Kochlöffel durchgerührt habt,
dürfte die Masse jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr so heiß sein.
Kratzt sie einfach aus und verknetet alles schön miteinander.
[Musik]
Also für den Katzenkopf die Masse so ein bisschen drücken.
So wird sie schön kompakt.
Und erst einmal eine schöne runde Form.
So ein bisschen kann man ja die Schnauze schon vormodellieren.
[Musik]
So, und dann werde ich den Kopf jetzt erst einmal in Folie einpacken
und ihn schön aushärten lassen, bis die Marshmallows fest sind.
Danach kann ich ihn so ein bisschen schnitzen
und dran rum modellieren.
Der Kopf ist jetzt fest und wird von mir modelliert.
Ich nehme immer diese Schablonen zur Hilfe und ich glaube,
Ich muss noch ein bisschen an der Schnauze was wegschneiden.
Er bekommt er diesen entsetzten Gesichtsausdruck
und alles andere regle ich jetzt mit Fondant.
Das wird schon.
Auf jeden Fall kriegt er erst einmal ein paar Bäckchen.
[Musik]
Jetzt mache ich einmal eine komplette Schicht um den Kopf herum.
Dazu rolle ich die Modelliermasse ein bisschen dicker aus als sonst.
[Musik]
Dann einmal drüberlegen
und hier hinten jetzt schön zusammenbringen und einfach wegschneiden.
[Musik]
Ich spieße mir jetzt kurz den Kopf hier auf ein Torten-Dummy.
Das ist einfach so ein Styropor-Block.
Mit einem kleinen Modellierwerkzeug, einem Metall-Strohhalm
oder ein Rundholz.
Dann kann ich jetzt da dran besser arbeiten.
Wichtig ist nämlich jetzt,
dass die Gesichtszüge auch gut verarbeitet werden.
D.h., hier vorne die Schnauze ein bisschen eindrücken.
Da kommt ja gleich Weiß drüber.
Hier bei den Augen eine Öffnung rein
und hier an den Seiten ein bisschen schmäler.
Da werde ich jetzt ein bisschen was mit Weiß
für den inneren Part auf den auf der Nase mischen.
So, dann die Schnauze.
Da habe ich jetzt hier einfach den Part so modelliert.
Aber das klebe ich erst an, wenn der untere Part dran ist.
Der offene Mund…
Ein offener Mund ist immer ein bisschen schwierig,
aber das kriegen wir hin.
[Musik]
Ich schneide jetzt einfach den Mund ein,
denn ich brauche später die Tiefe.
[Musik]
Ich klebe jetzt schon einmal schwarzen Fondant in die Mundhöhle,
damit ich da diese Tiefe und diesen schwarzen Raum bekomme.
Jetzt wird hier noch die Zunge modelliert
- einfach so ein Stück, ein bisschen Rot und Rosa gemischt.
In die Mitte dieses… wie heißt denn das?
Dieser Satzungenspalt…
Zungenspalt…
Und dann klapp ich das hinten so ein.
Unter den Mund kommt jetzt ein weißer kleiner Fleck.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Kinn.
Alles, was ich jetzt anklebe,
klebe ich einfach mit essbarem Zuckerkleber an!
[Musik]
Die untere Lippe ist jetzt dran.
Jetzt wird als Nächstes die Schnauze drangeklebt,
aber ich arbeite mich vom Hintergrund zum Vordergrund.
Die Augen liegen ja weiter hinten
und deswegen werde ich jetzt zuerst einmal die Augen modellieren.
Dafür nehme ich mir diese Schablone,
die ich jetzt doch in relativer Echtgröße als Vorlage
noch einmal ausgedruckt habe.
Da kann ich das Ganze nämlich ich in Folie packen
und die Augen hier entsprechend groß vorbereiten.
Immer wenn der Fondant ein bisschen klebt,
könnt ihr einfach Bäckerstärke nutzen,
um die Hände einzumehlen.
Ich nehme einfach so ein kleines Stück, was tropfenförmig ist,
und drücke es in die richtige Form.
Ihr könnt es auch mit dem Ausrollstab ausrollen und zuschneiden.
Aber so kriegt man die Form eigentlich relativ schön
und vor allem schön rund hin.
[Musik]
Dann ran an die Torte.
Dann habe ich hier diese Schnauze,
die jetzt auch ungefähr hier reinpasst.
In der Mitte diese Rille rein.
Für die Schnauze nehme ich jetzt hier noch einen Zahnstocher,
damit die große Schnauze da auch dran haften kann
und so ein bisschen besseren Halt hat.
Dann ist jetzt die Nase dran.
Da einfach so ein kleines Dreieck formen und draufsetzen.
Es kommen noch die Wangen dran.
Dafür einen Tropfen formen.
Also erst eine Kugel,
dann einen Tropfen,
dann schön flach drücken
und wie bei Tom einfach diese Katzenhärchen reinzeichnen.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Ohren dran
und ich schneide jetzt hier einmal so eine Spitze aus,
klebe sie hier drauf,
[Musik]
rolle nochmals drüber, dann hält es auch extrem gut.
Aber schön darauf achten, dass Grau außen ist.
Dann hier drumherum schneiden.
Den linken Part knicke ich so ein bisschen drüber,
damit das Ganze so ein bisschen dreidimensionaler wird.
Ich denke, wenn ich das dann so knicke und so trocknen lasse,
wirkt das schon wie das echte Ohr.
Das muss ich so noch einmal für das linke Ohr hinbekommen.
Ehm, ja…
[Musik]
Damit es auch schön in Form bleibt,
kann ich jetzt hier zum Aushärten,
denn das ist ja auch jetzt Modelliermasse,
kann ich einfach so ein bisschen Küchenpapier reintun.
Dann klappt das nicht runter und dann kann es so antrocknen
und irgendwie kriege ich es dann auch an die Torte befestigt.
Wie, weiß ich noch nicht, aber es wird irgendwie.
Jetzt die kleinen, angsterfüllten Augen.
Dafür erst einmal ein bisschen grün,
weil er ja durch die Torte fliegt
und dann fliegt er wahrscheinlich vom Hotel runter.
Deswegen hat er ein bisschen Angst.
[Musik]
Und dann noch Schwarz drauf.
Weiter geht's zu den Augenbrauen.
Dafür ein schwarzes Stück Fondant halbieren,
eine lange Rolle machen und so ein bisschen einschneiden
und dann schön gebogen drankleben.
[Musik]
Der gute Tom ist jetzt trocken.
Die Ohren werde ich erst kurz vorher auf die Torte setzen,
aber ich finde, das sieht schon ziemlich cool aus.
Was ich jetzt noch habe
- das ist jetzt das einzige, was nicht essbar ist -,
ist einfach ein schwarzer Draht für die Schnurrhaare.
Die kommen hier relativ mittig rein - 2 auf jeder Seite.
[Musik]
Dann fehlt mir noch auf jeden Fall der Lichtpunkt auf der Nase.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall noch eine Hand modellieren,
denn wenn er so aus der Torte raus schaut, denke ich,
könnte hier unten seine Pfote schon so ein bisschen rausschauen.
[Musik]
Das ist Tom. Tom ist eine Katze
und möchte Jerry fangen.
Jerry ist die Maus.
[Musik]